بقينا وحتى حل الظلام ولم
يكن هناك ما يمكننا فعله
لأنني لا أستطيع الوصول إلى مكانها
[موسيقى]
عدت إلى المنزل وعائلتي كان أطفالي
هنا
يطلبون نالا وأقول إنك
تعلم
أنها موجودة هناك في  قالت الجبال
إنها ربما تعاني من انخفاض حرارة الجسم
وتذهب للنوم وتتجمد ،
لم نأكل ، أعني أنه حتى الأطفال
لم تكن لديهم شهية في يوم
عشية عيد الميلاد ويمكنهم ارتدائه كما هو الحال في هذا
المزاج
[موسيقى]
لقد شعروا بالحزن ، كما تعلمون لم نتمكن من ارتدائه
تحمل تفكيرها وهي تعظ
هناك وهي وحيدة ولكن عمرها 22 شهرًا
[موسيقى]
تضحك
لذا
أقول إن علي الذهاب إليها لأنها على قيد الحياة
كان ينتظر وينتظر فقط
لأنني كنت أخشى أن تخاف نالا
من المتسلقين  التي كانت
لأنها لم تكن تعرف ، لكني أعتقد أن
أحد المتسلقين أعطاه لحم بقري متشنج
، وهكذا فازوا بها بشدة
، كانت أفضل هدية عيد الميلاد حصلت عليها
خلال 64 عامًا ،
ونحن ممتنون جدًا لاستعادتها و
ومحددة  أنا ممتن لفريق التسلق
، أعني أنه كان يوم عيد الميلاد
وتركوا عائلاتهم
وأحبائهم ويذهبون وينقذونك أنت تعرف آه نفسي
والكلب كان ذلك بمثابة عمل شجاع عظيم